une cérémonie qui débutait aux aurores
ou même la nuit dans les différentes
régions du pays malgré tout certains
n'ont pas voulu manquer de la visionner
en direct comme ce fut le cas pour une
cinquantaine de Néo-Écossais choisi
grâce à une loterie et qui ont pu se
déplacer à la résidence du lieutenant
gouverneur à Halifax
plus tard matinée une cérémonie avec le
Premier ministre tem Houston s'est
déroulé à l'extérieur pour la levée de
l'étendard royale ça permet de se situer
dans le temps ces événements là au fond
parce que on essaye de se dire mais
qu'est-ce qui se passait au moment où a
eu lieu le dernier couronnement
l'étendard royal a aussi flotté devant
queenspark la lutte Nantes gouverneur de
l'Ontario le Premier ministre et des
chefs autochtones ayant invité la
population a marqué la journée du
couronnement du roi Charles
le repère des Britanniques à Montréal
n'a pas voulu laisser passer l'occasion
de souligner l'événement de manière très
british avec goûté et t'aide
accompagnement
on a reçu 170 personnes pour des Haïti
moi je pense peut-être c'est une Racer
décoration habits spéciaux tout y était
pour créer une ambiance de fête on ne
fait comme un
pacte tous pour porter un genre de
chapeau donc on a fait un petit peu de
bagages en ligne ça fait rien si tu es
pour pas pour le monarque c'est une
chose communitaire c'est une chose de
faire un célébration entre tout le monde
évènement historique le couronnement du
monarque britannique est aussi une
occasion pour se rassembler ici Carla
Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal